[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two life-long friends talk about
life for a long time i'm wretched and
i'm linked this week at the round table
of dim lighting
we're gonna plan the perfect day for the
other person yeah and i'm gonna plan
your perfect day right i'm gonna plan
your perfect day and just so you know
uh we have committed to not having
planned it yet
so because we were both like this wasn't
our idea i think this was like the
somebody from the mythical crew
suggested
that we do an episode where we we
planned a perfect day for each other you
know if you guys are such good friends
you should be able to do that yeah and
then we're like man do we want to do
this episode i don't want to sit here
and think about playing it a day for you
especially if i'm not going to actually
do it and so that's when you're like hey
you know what this will be a fun
exercise
to literally come up with it in the
moment so i have kept myself from
thinking about your perfect day but i'm
going to tell you right now
by the end of this episode you will have
a perfect day plan that you can tap into
at any time
well
i'd be really good at playing in my own
perfect house can i just do that that's
the
well we need to talk about the ground
rules for that but
we've got some other things to update
everybody on before we get to
get to that oh yeah
i wanted to give an update on the party
on the the mythical christmas party
which happened
in uh
spring spring but um because i built
that up we were talking about how okay
we're gonna get we're gonna do it that
night and
we gotta say that we have a phone number
we have a near biscuit's phone number we
tweeted this out yes but we weren't very
excited about it
we wanted to make it where not only
could you tweet and use hashtag ear
biscuits to
give feedback on the show and also to
respond to prompts that we put out there
but we say you know what we want to
we want to be able to hear your voices
it's like an old-school radio show man
it's like calling in so 1888 earpod one
one eight eight eight earpod
one the number one the number one now
we're gonna use this number uh
for a couple of things now when we do a
prompt
uh where we like hey we wanna hear your
stories about this your perspective on
this we're gonna use that number
that's what we're going to do next week
we already we already tweeted out that
prompt if you want to see now go over
there but just because of the way that
the timing works with when we record
these and when we do those prompts those
props are most often going to be on
twitter right so you need to be
following mythical on twitter if you
want to see those prompts and then you'd
be like oh i can call the number and
leave my message and then we might use
it on an episode now one of the things
some people have talked about i saw some
people say
oh i don't want to do this because i
don't like calling numbers or i don't
like uh i think it's a generational
thing they don't call numbers anymore
and they don't want their voice to be
heard somewhere because it puts you on
the spot i have an idea okay
you could
record a voice memo on your phone of
what you want to say
and then you could and you could do it
until you get it how you want it and
then whenever you call in you have to
use a second phone oh you gotta have a
burner phone you gotta have a burner
phone and then you gotta play the
message
from your other phone i don't know if
you can call a number and play a voice
memo at the same time you can probably i
don't think that works you can play it
from your computer assuming you have a
computer or you have a person with
another phone you know what don't worry
about it like we just
talk on top of our heads and like if
things come out sideways we won't we
won't make fun of you yeah i promise
we're not going to make fun of you
should i promise that yeah and
say so that's how we're going to use it
got another solution but we're no no
well i was going to say you could
learn how to use a phone you could do
that thing where like you type it in and
then like the robot reads it if you
really want to do it but i would just
say they're not going to choose that use
this as an opportunity to be like hey
i'm going to i'm going to overcome this
fear and i'm going to leave a voice
message if that's a fear of yours and
we'll hey we're accepting dudes and
it'll be okay the second thing we're
gonna accepting all people not just
dudes
we are accepting dudes as in the two of
us are accepting dudes yeah we are
the
uh other thing we're gonna use the
number four is
anytime
anything that you want you have a
question for us that's completely
unrelated to something that we talked
about you have a comment about something
you have a thought about something that
we said something we got wrong something
we need to correct a perspective on
something maybe we'll listen to that and
be like hey somebody left a message
about that and then at some point later
we'll go back and address that so i like
this audio reaction you can do whatever
you want to on this line but i would
just say keep it short relatively brief
or
brief not even relatively brief uh
because it will up the chances that we
hear it and use it yeah that's right i
mean speaking of feedback
you know uh we're seeing feedback on the
last episode it's like man you guys keep
enough with the friendship talk and then
there's people like i love the
friendship episodes
and so
it's you know
i i get it i get both i actually favored
it on twitter uh some some feedback that
was like i'm tired of
you regurgitating all these friendship
stories it's kind of boring to me you
know what i honestly i'm something we've
discussed i'm i'm on team i'm tired of
it too
uh and so i guess i i you know i think i
i'd love for for us to be able to talk
about topical things and
uh just hypothetical things and answer
your questions or hear your perspectives
on things i actually think today's
episode is even though it's not exactly
in that category
but it's
uh
this is an exercise in us trying to
figure out how to plan the perfect day
for each other which it's a lo to me it
reminds me of an old school rabbit hole
episode where we would just take
something and run with it the fact that
we have not thought about it and talked
about it ahead of time there's no
preview and we haven't even worked it
out on our own to me this is the kind of
thing i get excited about to me i guess
i get excited about variety and if you
go back to the same well
which is like maybe our shared
experiences from the past too much
especially in a formatted way
then yeah i you know we can get kind of
bored with it so yeah we we appreciate
the feedback we're kind of on the same
page already
and just like saying hey we want to mix
things up you want to have the the light
fun episodes i mean what
one of the problems with that just a
little inside baseball is that like when
your show's not just one thing
it's harder to promote and for new
audience to come in and we want people
to discover your biscuits and like
be folded into the fold but it's like
if it's just the two of us
talking about our past or about anything
it's like it's kind of hard to
understand you really got to give it
some time
so
you know you're special because you've
given it the time you're committed we
appreciate that and we want to hear from
you 188 earpod one also leave us if you
want there's something you want to hear
us talk about you know any anything you
want and also do that with gear biscuits
because we are still reading all these
things so multiple options
um so we built up we were recording a
podcast and then we were going to the
party
in our
uh
parking lot we had on your dj last night
i had on my dj suit and i was like yeah
i'm i i i'd worked up some playlists
because somebody had to do it and i i
really loved that and and you told me
that uh
because you it's it's interesting for
someone who is an aspirational dj
uh
your your sort of approach with a party
is that the music is
not too loud like you can still have a
conversation
and then
multiple times in multiple settings over
the past few years i've heard you
legitimately say people don't
like people don't like to dance right
like you you you'll be like people don't
like people no one's gonna want to dance
every playlist that i've made is for a
party that usually i've had at my house
where it's like old people we're just
hanging out
and we're talking we're catching up
we're having some libations
we're chilling out by the fire pit we're
taking it easy it's a kickback vibe yeah
and you're very good at the party and i
already had a couple of those playlists
cooked up but then i had this sneaking
suspicion in the back of my mind that it
was gonna be a little too laid back and
i said that but we get to the party
and it's um
we had a couple of food trucks we had
tables set out and then people are
getting their like korean barbecue and
there's like the vegan food truck and
hey options for everybody we're
accepting dudes and then
we're accepting all people
and vegans included they all came to the
party it was like the first outdoor
unmasked thing that everybody could be
at i was like people are going to want
to connect they're going to meet for the
first time we had the name tags so that
people like me with name fright would be
like hey
i know who you are because you've
written it on your
person yeah and people are and i'm
playing i got cute with that and put
brett on mine
that's cute yeah
and so i was playing my kickback
instrumentals playlist no lyrics
nothing to interfere with conversation
but a nice
just
mid-tempo vibe to eat some barbecue and
sit down and talk to people i'm like man
this is going good there's a little bit
of mingling happening
uh we're having a good time
everybody's eating
and that took you know an hour and a
half maybe two hours and then we
uh
we gave a speech
and um
i don't know it always seems like you
know what you want to say
and i'm like don't know
and i hadn't even thought about it but
i'm here for it and i'm glad to be
speaking
but not not know what i'm trying to
convey that's a great one-two punch oh
yes a one-two punch
i didn't really know what i was gonna
say until right before don't say that
that makes me feel worse but but you
didn't think about it i thought about it
like it was i think i thought about it
in points it i have three points do you
remember the points no hey i mean come
on they would they'd love to hear your
speech
like paraphrased
wow okay jenna you might have to help
with this if it was that memorable oh
you think jenna remembers your speech
she was the too many libations
um don't throw jenna under the bus it
was early in the evening
i think i said something like
uh it's great to be back together
to see the bottom half of your faces
um yeah
that community is such a big part of
what we have built here
and there's something about being
together
and actually being in the same physical
space and i'm just so excited that we're
able to do this i it was about
i tapped into the community aspect of
what we were experiencing and i was like
what he said
you kind of took it all
i can't remember what i said i think i
said i love all of you
there was some kind of joke about
i put my hand on your shoulder
and i said i was like you know sometimes
and i put my hand on your shoulder like
sometimes
um
if you come into our office we this we
do this when we when we uh are like
struggling it was a there was there was
an impromptu moment where there was
something about there's a joke there was
a joke about
when we're struggling and we're
dependent on each other and we you we
might come into our office and we're and
we're doing this and then like you
turned and we did that we did like a
physical joke oh yeah and then i made an
hr joke which i hate making hr jokes we
always tend to make a
but ellen was there and so i was just
like if you are gonna touch someone on
the shoulders check with ellen first or
something like that
you know i don't like to make those
jokes and i wouldn't have made that joke
if i had really see this is why i plan
things
because when you don't plan things you
end up making that joke and everybody
laughed and everybody knew it was you
know harmless and we're talking about
shoulder touching and i made the the i
the one thing i do remember saying was
the phrase
now we're going to kick this party up a
notch oh sorry i don't know what
remember i said something like that and
i don't you were feeling it this is this
is i don't know natural dj instagram i
don't know why i said that because i
wasn't thinking
i'm not prepared to kick it i was
thinking i had a playlist that was going
to take it up like one notch okay so
what so then i started but then i wasn't
ready to play it yet because there were
a few more songs in my existing playlist
give me an example of what the middle
playlist was the taking it up one notch
well it it had lyrics
okay so it was some uh it had lyrics it
was some it was some
late 90s rap which i thought would
connect
like uh
ice cubes today was a good day but still
kind of like
yeah still vibrant we're all interacting
with each other and but i didn't change
the playlist yet and i went back and sat
down and and uh jenna leaned over and
she said
is
is this your idea of kicking it up a
notch
and i was like
uh yeah i don't know why i said that
prematurely because i wasn't ready to
kick it up a notch is this your right
and i was like you know what i can do
that i can do that and i went over there
and then like i started
i actually i think i went to use the
bathroom i was like oh i got to compose
myself and when i came back out jenna
said i don't think she came up to me and
it was like a little like
um i'm whispering even though there's no
one around yeah right and she was like
i people are coming up to me because i
don't think that they're comfortable
coming up to you
i love this and they're they're just
asking
could we have
music with you know with like lyrics
okay
the music already had a beat okay and
then she was like you know i think
people want to dance and i was like
people want to dance and i looked around
at how everyone there was younger than
me well and i was like you know
significantly younger i'm like oh yeah
the people who work here
yeah they're they're in a different
headspace when they want it i was like
but they haven't seen each other for for
so long so many people have never met
don't they just want to sit down and
talk
and i was like no
we did it already we did it already
we've been doing that and i'm like
i'm like okay okay well then i'm
thinking
my backup to my backup playlist to take
it up a second notch
is still not taking us to the dance
floor you weren't prepared for a dance
party i wasn't prepared for a dance
party and that was i was such a huge
blind spot for me yeah well every dj's
got to have that moment wake up call
this is going to be in your dj when you
write your dj autobiography
this is going to be the chat is going to
be called wake up call
and you're going to tell this story yeah
so then i go uh you know i read
questlove's book
and did he have a wake-up call he had a
wake-up call he tells this fantastic
story of
how
uh president obama he was
a
sitting president at the time
invited him to an event and
um
quest love had been working on a set
list
for like months and months and months
leading up to this and it was like going
it was like this amazingly intricate
like
uh goes from a to b go through goes
through the history of
music and it's like this amazing
uh
intricate
set list
and then he's playing it for obama this
is like this is a big moment for him
and then
after a while
uh
president obama comes up to him pulls
him aside and and uh you know he does an
impression of him and he's basically
like
um can you can you play something for
the kids
can you play something for the kids
and that's my obama by the way that's
pretty good
and um
he was crushed
he started good he had to start googling
on his phone i mean
it's not that he didn't know what the
kids would want to listen to what kids
the obama kids um the younger people who
were there
the kids and then
so like can you play some current um
some current hits
you know and so he sw so he like totally
off the on the fly just had to regroup
entirely
and then he had to start playing
had to start playing
what the people wanted to hear
right then and and dance to and then
uh
then i think there's a part of the story
where he's like
uh when it was all over when the party
was over he just
he he snuck away
and just left
and he said that he couldn't dj for like
the year oh my it was like a huge deal
for him and
this is a much better story than yours
i'm so grateful to hear his much better
story because then i was like you know
what i'm just i don't i don't even i'm
not a dj i don't even have dj equipment
yet i'm sitting here with a with spotify
hold on but you're right get you are
gonna buy some and then at this point
i'm like all right so
i start i start kicking it up
with what i with what i know i'm playing
some
i'm playing some late 90s
rap and people are going on the dance
floor and then i'm like i'll take
requests
and then based on the first few requests
i mean these are songs that i that i
knew of i was aware of them and i would
like find them and put them in the queue
and then i was like i hope people don't
see this and then i like took those
songs and i started googling like i'm
like these people like mid
like mid 2000's dance floor
hit the dance floor like i'm literally
googling this and then i'm over there
like oh okay and then i'm throwing songs
in the playlist and i'm like okay now i
got this people are giving requests it's
getting dark everybody's dancing and you
know what
it started to work it started awesome
the thing i was observing because i was
not party to any of this i wasn't
talking to i didn't talk to you other
than when we'd give a speech
we tend to yeah we tend to separate uh
right and glad hand separately yeah
we're too exciting we're two accepting
dudes
um
but the thing i noticed was i hadn't
seen
the mythical crew together
to that degree and we also had the smosh
crew
you know in two years and yeah we've
hired a bunch of people over the past
two years
and you know we keep getting older and
we keep hiring people who are younger
and so
there are
just a lot of most people are in their
20s and many of them are like in their
early and mid-20s right
and
there's just a different life stage man
and yeah they they want to dance and it
was just like
once they started hearing what they
wanted to hear it was like a release and
it and you know what it was like letting
people out of
you know
they would have been like cooped up yeah
socially
and they were just letting loose it was
a beautiful thing to watch it did feel
good to see the mythical crew and the
smosh crew come together and hang out
and have a good time and nobody wanted
to leave the party they all just wanted
to
dance or hang around the edge and like
the party really took a turn thank you
jenna for breaking the news and i was
like i went up to christy and i was like
yeah this is this is i've really gotta
i've really gotta make some adjustments
she was like you can do it babe she's
like being very supportive and then so
then yeah yeah the party started jumping
yeah and i was like
googling and taking requests and
figuring it out and people were like
looking at me like man he's just taking
this really seriously can i can i get
you just as you're you know i believe in
this career evolution i i i like the
idea of
your dj phase
uh you know we're jokingly calling you
dj rhett but i honestly think you need
to you know you really need to are you
going to be dj strawbeat well you know i
like that you know whatever you're going
to be i mean i think you need to take
some time and you need to figure that
out
um dj guy from the internet yeah but
like i do have a vision of you
you know
us going to like parties and like yo
there's link he's link's here and dj
whatever is here and he's doing his
thing
now my
my only note at this point is
facial expression okay so in that moment
okay yeah and i think this is why uh
this is good okay i'll take i'm taking
notes i think this is why even on facial
expressions this is why um who are the
two guys where the helmets the daft pump
daft punk and then who's the guy that
wears the big mouse uh dead dead mouse
marshmallow yeah you're saying i need to
i'm gonna need a mask okay okay i want
to wear a mask of my of your face call
themselves pretty funny
or wear a mask of my own face making the
expression that apparently you're about
to tell me i need to make the reason
that they my theory is why they wear
helmets is because
uh
it's very difficult to not look like
you're trying and you have a very like
there's a very specific face that you
make when you're concentrating and
trying and you kind of you start you
kind of go into like you look a little
bit like an old man trying to figure
something out right oh you like this
like yeah yeah yeah and so
whereas i think most
exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's it
and so i think that most cool djs either
have a helmet or they found a way to
look super happy and effortless the
whole time that everything is happening
so i i don't i'm not telling you what
you should do at the beginning are you
talking about the beginning or like once
i got in like once it was like i
recovered i'm saying you even in the
recovery there was like the old man well
i when you would look down there would
be like a crinkle of there would be a
crinkle of the brow it'd the person who
pointed this out to me was your wife
so i'm sitting with jesse and christy
and she's like look at him
he's trying so hard
and i looked and i was like yeah this
guy is he's doing a good job but he
doesn't look like he's doing it yeah
yeah you gotta it's kind of like in the
when we in the book of the calendar
we're talking about confidence it's all
about the look on your face yeah yeah
you're exactly right what i'm a
mask is not a bad idea so
i learned so much that night and this is
the last piece of the puzzle because i
derived
so many things that why you need a dj
needs equipment it's like when you're
when you're just using a spotify
playlist you're not a dj because
i would i would look at the dance floor
but all right this song is too long this
song needs to end and the next song
needs to go ahead and play and it needs
to blend but the next song needs to
start after the intro i had no
capability to do any of that so that's
what the equipment allows you if you you
can't even crossfade songs using spotify
unless you let them play to completion
and then the next one starts to
completion you can't do it manually in
order to make a transition
you had to stop the song and start the
next one and i was trying to do that i
was like deriving what it meant to be a
dj as if no one had ever done i do
believe there was one time in which a
song kind of abruptly ended and you said
sorry yeah yeah i so i did have a
microphone yeah and a couple of requests
were like
like the worst thing to play at that
moment and i was like i would call the
person i'll be like hey this is on so
and so i this is not my decision so i
learned like you can't take requests all
the time yeah this is like a crash
course and dealing that was like
throwing throwing myself to the wall
yeah right yeah but now i'm realizing so
i
after that night
i ordered a dj deck i know you ordered
one i already have it really yeah last
weekend
um
i set the thing up and in my living room
and i had the headphones and i was using
my speakers and i stayed up until like 2
30 in the morning just pretending to be
djing a party
that nobody was at
and you know what it was so much fun
is it software like how does it load
it's serato
dj dj light is free and then it connects
to the board which like simulates two
turntables where is it getting the music
from uh you can connect it with
a str with title or soundcloud so i had
to get a title subscription oh so you're
playing like the high res playing the
high res stuff and you know what
i wasn't doing it to out yes i was
pretending to be at a party kind of and
like thinking about my experience and
like what would i've done if i would
have had this equipment oh yeah i would
have done this this is what i want this
is what i wanted to do this is how i
would want to mix these songs
and it's like i haven't really figured
it out yet but it the main thing is it's
like it's it's an exercise in active
listening i mean for the whole pandemic
i really got into listening to music
voraciously like
and making playlists that's where this
whole
thing started
and so this is like another level of
it's it's active listening you're like
participating in it and there's like
there's knobs and it's very tangible and
like you're learning software and
there's a really big part of this that
is about control
you know which obviously resonates with
my proclivities to like say okay can i
control people's and react to people's
responses
and
give them a good time like i i love this
well i really think this may be my
calling well interesting that you say
that uh because you know
uh and i think this is a good channeling
of that because it is true like
oftentimes if we're like in a group
setting
um
you know my my wife is the one that will
point this out to you sometimes
it's like
okay link you feel like you're trying to
she'll bring something up you'll be like
i don't want to talk about that you
don't say that but you indicate that you
don't want to talk about that right now
you're kind of trying to keep a
conversational flow according to what
you think we should be talking about
yeah
um
but i think that this is a way for you
to
exercise some control in a way that
serves the group in a way that no one
else is going to do right
uh and you can like control the vibe of
the of a party without controlling the
conversation of a party but it is a
conversation
i mean it's not just control one way
it's a two-way street because you gotta
you gotta read the room
yeah um but now i'm realizing the one
other piece
that i need for my dj setup is a mirror
to check your teeth no just to check the
look on my face oh like i'm gonna put a
mirror down here
lando makes fun of me he says every time
you look in the mirror and fix your hair
dad you make a you make it you make this
face
oh yeah i'm like no i don't i mean i i'm
like yeah i think i do i i i'm i'm yeah
if i had a mirror there but i'm being
honest about this i feel like it would
be super cool and maybe i don't know i'm
not throwing anything out there but
maybe i am um
you could get the mythical beasts to
help out with this
but like i think there's an opportunity
to achieve some sort of persona you know
like
some name and maybe there is like okay
he always wears suits you know he's
always got matching tops and bottoms and
he this is
this is his helmet this is what's on his
head i mean this i'm just saying there's
the possibilities are pretty limitless
and i never understood it
i never understood the helmets in the
mouse head and the marshmallow until
this moment
and now it's all making sense to me that
like i think i can i don't want to wear
a helmet it's probably hot in there
probably well you can get a cool one
that has a built-in cooling
wow
yeah
or or or you know or you could just
learn the face what about just a hat
it could be a hat but i'm saying like
you got to have a name because right
because this dj rhett thing is kind of
catching on now
and you got to stop that from happening
yeah i think yeah that
right it can't happen this can't just
can't be
this can't be your thing when you have
nothing to do with it right
become front and center of the thing
i mean it's pretty funny it is funny but
it's it's a chapter in the book
the dj red days
yeah as long as i suck i can be called
that right and then like when i realized
that okay
i think i've got something to offer to
the world
then i gotta i gotta come out with my
real name
yeah
yeah because you put some thought into
that
because then you could act different and
everything it's like actually i'm
showing
i'm showing up as this guy
yeah yeah and
i could wear matching
matching suits and
which is kind of what i already did
right that's what i'm saying yeah you're
laying the groundwork for this i could
wear i could wear overalls
and but i do think that you're gonna
have to bring coveralls jenna every time
yeah yeah yeah because she's gonna have
to be
figuring out what somebody will come out
and whisper whisper it too well i think
she'll have a sh you'll have an earpiece
in your helmet and she'll have a little
little microphone
jenna be like the face
work on the face you're doing that face
again
you're doing the old man face okay well
we haven't even planned our days thank
you for indulging me that was an update
on the party i didn't mean to make it
all about me and my dj experience but
everybody had a good time we when when
we were nobody wanted to leave
yeah i mean i i i you left i i ducked
out about i kept playing music at 8 30
or so and then because i i i did this
trick where i kept playing music and
then everyone who stayed we got them to
help clean up well i knew that was going
to happen so so i left yeah
no i left because i did my i did my
little dance
you know my dancing has gotten much more
reserved over the years with my back
situation so i did my little dance in
the circle and then i
i popped out
and then i was like okay you know you
you kids have fun daddy's going home to
go to sleep but my yeah my idea is i'm i
want to be a barbecue dj i'm still more
of a i'm more of a laid-back
mode i'm not like i'm not going to the
club that is not my aspiration i want to
go to the barbecue
okay i like to have it i want to have it
a little bit more laid back
but i can't but i'd like but i need to
have it in my repertoire
to hit the dance floor
man we waited a long time to do our
promo it usually comes earlier uh what
are we what are we promoting today here
read this script this is a promotion uh
that involves you
before we get to the rest of the episode
we wanted to tell you about an exciting
upcoming episode of best friends back
all right all right now we talked about
bfba a few times on the show the show
where stevie and nagin reconnect after
15 years apart and this week it's a
great show a little different
on this friday's episode i
rhett
not dj red just rhett will be guesting
on the show and talking to stevie and
negine about everyone's favorite high
school period
lunch time
it's not periods i mean they've already
thought about periods i'm sure they're
just talking about their favorite like
lunch time the favorite high school
period
search for best friends back all right
on your favorite podcast app or click
the link in the episode description so f
to follow so you don't miss friday's
episode
uh and while you're over there check out
some of the other incredible episodes of
the podcast i wonder if nagin is going
to hate you
no i know me i kind of hope nagin hates
you by that i know that would be
hilarious to listen to we get along
great i'm going to listen to see if
nagin hates rhett
okay all right
uh let's let's let's plan
the perfect day for the other guy the
only thing i thought about is a few
ground rules
um
you know me i love rules
um
that was a joke uh
i think that this something is should be
something that is like possible yeah
yeah let's keep it something that we
could be feasible it's a feasible thing
we're talking and we're talking 12 hours
or 24 hours
i think we should stick with the day
i think this is like when you wake up
when you go to bed so it could be a
little bit longer than normal okay okay
i also don't think that um
i don't think it can involve any
extensive travel because that's not a
great day like it's gotta be really
justified i'm gonna fly you to hawaii
well yeah what about that five hour
flight you gotta fly back
yeah it wouldn't work you gotta you have
to wake up in your own bed and go to
sleep in your own bed so i think that
rules out extensive travel it's just a
day it's not a it's not an overnight
trip and this is something that if um
if we so chose
we could implement and actually pull off
oh so it's not like well i'm gonna get
you know i'm gonna get quest love
to come and
give you a personalized dj lesson yeah
cause that would be super cool but i
just don't know if i can pull that off
i don't yeah he wouldn't sniff the the
hole
on fallon i tried to get him to sniff
the right i remember that
get him to smell the hole he said no of
the cinnamon roll yeah um so i think
it's got to be something that i didn't
get to talk to him afterward you know
that like i if if i'm planning your
thing i know that i could do it if i
wanted to vice versa all right yeah yeah
doesn't involve any maybes or what if
it's this is actually could happen okay
all right
and it doesn't necessarily have to
involve the other guy
you could just be like a concierge for
me you don't have to be there
if it's if the idea is better without
you then you've got to be willing to not
be there
right because it's my perfect day it's
not our perfect day that might put a
little bit of uh because one of the
things that i'm saying i'm just saying
it could go either way well you remember
that time i uh i have the freedom of
disinviting you i picked your you and
your girlfriend at the time up i took
you on a date and i turned my dodge
dynasty into a limousine
and the only thing i did was
i put a
sheet up between the front and back
seats and i put on a hat and i used an
english accent yeah i and i you know
what pardon my french but i would call
that [ __ ] boss
i mean yeah she was she was a little
uncomfortable
because it was like to have your best
friend take you on a date yeah like to
go
to go on a date with a guy and then his
best friend is acting like a chauffeur
and has a sheet up between you and
you're in character the whole time it
was very much about you yeah i was
putting on a show and i took you to like
a jazz uh remember that jazz themed
restaurant and waverly place and carrie
yeah i mean i
i booked the reservation yeah i didn't
plan
unlike now but i do you think it was my
idea or your idea to do that i think i
probably pitched it
yeah what if i you know you wanna do
something really nice let's get her a
limo driven by me and it's not a limo
it's the dynasty i'll put a sheet up
i'll use an english accent because all
chauffeurs are from england
this is
just a little insight into my 16 year
old mine we just saw it from the
perspective of
this is
this is hilarious and awesome and cool
but from her perspectives like yeah this
is a bit uncomfortable
and
i mean
strangely third wheelish but also this
is what you get when you were you're
dating link
yeah you get it that might show up
do you want to start go
i'm going to be your chauffeur for the
okay just all right and i will be using
an english accent and i
you know what um
yeah it's weird that's weird it's going
to be weird go ahead okay i'm just
saying i can okay you're gonna pick me
up at what time
well
what's the first thing
well first thing is i'm going to the day
before
i'm going to learn your smoothie recipe
because i know you gotta you gotta make
your smoothie but
just the process of making the smoothie
is starting to feel a little bit too
much like mother's day like you know
it's like
this seems like it you have to start
your day with the damn smoothie
that's part of it
yeah i just think give me give
give me time to make my own smell so
okay oh really perfect day is i make my
own smoothie you make your own smoothie
yeah yeah yeah
so you before you pick me up apparently
so this is gonna be the i could do
anything this is the perfect day
i've perfected my smoothie
it's a perfect start to the day i i
drink my coffee i drink my smoothie and
i take a poop and in there if i do those
three things then i'm like you know what
er i'm i'm ready to go i've got the
nutrients and i'm i'm cleaned out i'm
ready to go
okay
uh
this is you don't have to worry about
breakfast okay so i'm picking you up but
the question is
you family with you
like are you are you like because i feel
like the perfect day
my kids hell no okay so the kids are not
a joke but at this point i'm i was
assuming that uh
no i definitely think that the kids i
mean think about my kids i think there
might be a certain point where they show
up for a window of time for something
but the fact is is that i love my
children but i'm gonna see them the next
day right and
they're only they only have potential to
screw up the perfect day i hate you know
i hate to say that about them publicly i
love her your perfect day but teenagers
them in a position where they're not
having their perfect day because you
know that myself when you ask teenagers
like dad's having this perfect day right
and they're like oh crap we got to be a
part of it you know we got to be there
for this and then they've got a little
bit of attitude for mother's day and i
know you did this too like we had like
a six or seven hour
window of time where it was like
we went to an event that christy wanted
to go to and went out to
to lunch afterward but like that event
that we went to with all these shops
that christy went to it was like me and
lincoln and lando were just kind of
following her around and trying to keep
a smile on her face while she enjoyed
herself mother's day but it's like
and she was glad that we were there but
because it was mother's day but if it
was just her perfect day she probably
would have preferred to be shopping
at those shops and then meet up with us
later so yeah no harm no foul here my
wife got back from our mother's day
outing
and she said
that might have been the best mother's
day i've ever had
yeah but how and how was it for
you and the boys
uh
i mean
you so we went over to santa monica went
over to the west side
had a little
brunch at a place that's right there on
the beach
that's good brunch and then we drove
over to abbott kinney
nice shops and we just kind of expensive
we went up and down and it was more like
jessie's going where she wants to go and
we may go in with her or we may go to
another place and then what kind of this
is this roving thing yeah that's gonna
meet up with her yeah and so and i think
that the boys had a pretty good time
they got you know got get some pizza and
stuff we were there we basically stayed
out all day that's cool
now for me no shopping like don't don't
i don't want to go shopping okay so i
pick you up what time you want to be
picked up
um apparently seven thirty eight o'clock
eight o'clock eight o'clock three year
you know i don't want to waste a day um
now i mean
besides the travel
required to get across town
and we've had some pretty good days that
have started with surfing yeah
we haven't done that in a while it's
just we're we're just kind of for far
away from the ocean i'd like to do that
now you never know what you're gonna get
might get hurt with a surfing day
yeah it could be a could be a
a dud but i would say that i mean i'm
not putting in requests but for me
i think beginning the day was you know
that's what you know what
i'm honestly i'm actually changing all
right
i know you're planting a seed all right
i'll
we'll go surfing on your day but here's
the thing
i'm gonna rent you
a oceanfront house
so you wake up oh wow now we did this um
i don't know when it was
in the middle of the pandemic when we
were just having
a hell of a time
trying to be a family during the
pandemic and having kids that were just
so frustrated with not going to school
and you know not seeing their friends
um
my therapist who happens to be my wife's
therapist as well
was like hey um
you guys really just need to like
get change of scenery right
and we ended up we we rented a place we
haven't been i've been in la for i
remember for 11 years and have never
done this but we rented like one of
those places small but like
on the water in malibu where the water
the waves are hitting the house at night
that's nice i don't know about the owner
i don't know what you do when
the waves eventually take it down but
hey i'll rent it for a little bit
um
and i brought my my paddle board
and it was literally like you would just
you could just wake up
go down some steps you were on the beach
and then you're in the water like it
that's a that was a great way to start
the day so i'm going to rent a
beachfront
condo or
place for you
but since this is our perfect day
perfect
like we probably should both rent that
and spend the night there the night
before well no you got to start an end
in your own bed that's what you said oh
crap why did i make that rule but it's
just for the day so it's a little
splurgy but yeah you gotta you got a
home base with so you can get off the
beach and you can shower
and you can have as many topochicas as
you want i mean i'm not saying i'm not
requesting anything but and then you
move on to the next thing fully fully
showered
wash the sand out your butt cheeks
okay so at this point i feel like we're
pretty on i feel like my perfect day and
your perfect day are kind of in line at
this point i'm
well i don't have a smoothie
routine
yeah i think yours is so much it's gonna
be a lot it's gonna be pretty food
centric i think you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna care about breakfast
but we're gonna be in a hurry
so you're gonna want to go through the
mcdonald's drive through and get a
sausage and egg mcgriddles well
am i just accepting what you're
suggesting yep
so we're going through the mcdonald's
drive through yeah we're not doing a
sit-down breakfast because boy what this
what i have in store for your perfect
day you're not going to want to delay
okay so it's so i get a mcgriddles
yeah yeah
you love it man i mean it's a it's a
splurge i mean it's like a rare
thing it's rare to have something better
than a mcgriddles right
even at like some sit-down
breakfast place yeah you don't you think
you want it but you don't you might have
been thinking like what i did bro what
did you think you wanted well i was
going to say that just say it i was
going to say that just say it typically
a
perfect day for me is two meals
like if i go all right no food no
breakfast
well if i'm gonna be hungry we're going
to eat lunch at like
one you're gonna be starving it's gonna
be so good no lunch
when i go on vacation all right so we
want to bring dinner
well listen
like really big brunches and really big
dinners
that it sucks up too much time
to eat a really that's that's what i
want to know what you want i love eating
and i love going to do you want to go
places to eat
i don't like i don't want like my mom to
come and like cook for me like that's
what you're asking i love her cooking
but like i like going to a restaurant
all right fine but we're i mean we want
after the physical we're going to go
surfing and then the there's a physical
your perfect day has to start with a
physical
what i gotta turn and cough
you you gotta i'm gonna drop you off i'm
gonna make a special the first
appointment they've got at the doctor to
make sure i can go i just want you to be
fully checked out
like i just you know you never get
around to it
you never get around to no no i've been
i i i've been able to check you you need
a you need to be thoroughly checked out
i'm not going to get a physical i'm not
perfect yeah this is the most this
sounds horrible no think about it
dude you you're a hypochondriac
you want to be cleared you want to be
clear to the beginning of the day to be
like you know what i they've tested me
my blood my semen everything i can prep
for this i can do a blood test and a
physical and a semen test like a week
ahead of time no because what happens in
that week and i ain't talking about
covet here i'm talking about much much
worse than that okay let me talk about
cancer can i just say
can i just say that so i'm i'm thinking
of your best man so far i've i'm
chauffeuring you around renting you a
beach house in malibu and what you've
done for me is you got me a mcgriddles
and a physical
i ca yeah man i know the real you
like you're gonna be so freed up the
mcgriddles is a good idea for that
physical listen uh the physical is
unnecessary like when that doctor comes
out and is like listen man i could
nothing you cl you're totally clean tell
me about this doctor
he's smart he knows his stuff it's not
even like a hot female doctor what
what do you i mean if you're gonna make
me do a physical at least i need to find
like a little something needs to be fun
no man the fun is being cl is being
cleared of all worry
you're you're but like i get anxiety at
the doctor i get i have white coat white
coat blood pressure issues
so i just don't think this is a good
this is not getting me in the right mind
and if they do find something then it
becomes like your last day on earth like
it's like you know what i got bad news
you
you have you have one day to live but
it's like well good you know what this
is your perfect day
you just with a win-win okay let me get
back to what i'm doing for you so you
get done with your surfing session right
there get into the bungalow shower hold
on
i planned this in such a way as you
never know if the surf's gonna be good
and sometimes you can have a great time
regardless but we're talking i'm
planning this on a day when it's like
the waves are
consistent
it's smooth and glassy not too big so
you're not going to get hurt and you
just have those you know we've had a
couple of days like that and it's just a
great way to start the day being on the
water is a victory it doesn't matter
well i'm saying i'm planning this on a
day when there's good surf then
you come back into the house
and
i have hired um
just one of these like
really good
yoga
people
you know what i'm saying
maybe maybe like just a masseuse well
hold on
masseuse is part of it too
but this is a person who is like
super comforting and relaxing guru like
who after you come in and do whatever
you need to do shower wise
they've they've created this environment
in this malibu
place where it's like super soothing and
there's like this awesome playlist
playing no you know what
i'm going all out it's not a playlist it
is a live floutist it's a live band that
plays like spa music i think i can run a
band watching me do yoga they're not
they're all turned away from you
they're all turned into the corner okay
they're just there maybe they're in the
next room this is strange no no no
they're it feels strange and there's
like there's like
they make like they make the kind of
things that you the kind of noises that
you hear in this yoga music but it's all
live
and they're doing that live sound bath
and this is a person of your choice i
mean i can give you a list of i've got
multiple people because i know how you
are with people sometimes and so i've
given you like multi i've hired four
yoga instructions i'm supposed to look
at them and choose one of them no no
they are on the other side of a one-way
mirror that i've installed so they they
know they're being
no no no i tell them something like hey
this is a fun game i'm playing you've
been accused of a crime
now like this is a fun game i played
with my friend where i'm paying you full
price for your day all four of you but
only one of you is going to be chosen
because it's a
he comes from a weird religion where he
has to pick it feels a little brotherly
so you just want me to pick the person
for you because you might have a problem
with them
just
i don't like their voice you know i want
i want you to be able to see them
i appreciate what you're trying to do
and then choose them
and okay well just say somehow you
choose that person the band's going
they're doing their sounds they come in
and they lead you through just a really
relaxing stretching
little meditation
very very good stuff okay and then that
moves into
oh here comes a person they set up a
table
and ask you to disrobe and get on it
right this is the massage part okay
what we do is this the exam mine's just
later this is a
you thought you were a wild with a
four-hander this is a six-hand massage
so i'm talking three people doesn't have
to be three women in fact it probably
shouldn't be based on how your
four-hander went with the two women yeah
um
so
uh we've got
three i think it should be very
inclusive okay so you want two women one
man what do you want
[Laughter]
i don't know why
i've kind of positioned myself as a pimp
and you're in your tank it's like it
feels like i'm just
like i don't i don't want to be a pimp
that's not what i'm after in life you've
seen but somehow like bringing people to
you and you're making choices i'm sorry
that it's turned out this way on your
perfect day i do like a massage
so six-hander massage yeah yeah yeah
they just need to be it's all about they
need to be good at it oh this is not
about it's not about their gender it's
not about their this is the they are the
best it's not about how they look it's
about what they can do to my body only
okay and sincerely
they need to be good with the pressure
they need they need they need to be able
to like stay on that oh this is part of
it not not pop off of it yeah this is
all part of it they need to be good okay
we can move on
well shoot i gotta man you're right so i
mean i'm pretty good at this
oh yeah
um
jessie's listening she's like well
why is this just once again mother's day
you could be
this could be about me
it's like we're digging ourselves a hole
okay like i did this one i'm not doing
you right so that like chris is like
yeah he's saving it saving up his plans
for me i don't want to show her that i'm
like really creative and then i've been
holding back on her i don't want to show
her that i'm really creative
you're really digging hard
just give up on me now
you know okay so what were the bars so
what's happening because i'm also at the
the beach house you're in the beach
house yeah and then maybe a different
day
you don't like
i think you like yoga more than a
massage
are you in are you are you really
designing your own day here too is this
working for you well i mean like to me
it's more about crosstalk at this point
for you i think when you get off the
beach
like you've exerted yourself the thing
you want to do is eat
yeah so i think that's really got that
mcgriddle's rolling around i think
that's really
you burn that off man i think um
i think you want
i think you want a
well i in one sense it's like a buffet
but you don't buffet is not classy
so i mean if you all right so i'm
all right
there's a one-way mirror on the other
side of it there's like five chefs
now you're now you can see i'm choosing
the masseuse
based on skills you're choosing the chef
based on cuisine they're all like six
star shops okay i'm glad you're doing
this but six star is not a thing now one
thing i will say is one of the best
i've found that one of the things i
really like
uh is
and i've only done this like i have an
idea
but i went to this there was a weird
restaurant on the on the on the west
side where you kind of went into this
like
mall and you went up these stairs and it
was kind of like a speakeasy and i think
i talked about this on the show but
there was this weird door and you like
knocked on it and then you went into
this michelin
star restaurant and they got and it was
very small it could seat like 16 people
and the chef was this famous chef who
had moved from chicago to start this
restaurant in l.a
made it did a 12-course meal
and talked to you personally about each
thing that's not going to happen for you
what that's what i want here's what's
going to happen these six chefs
are gonna as you're trying to choose six
chefs or are they six chefs both and as
you're trying to choose which one you
want you can interview them through a
through a a microphone
that disguises your voice
one-way mirror and they're each like
telling you what they can do because if
we install a one-way mirror in the in
the in the condo we should probably use
it for both the
yeah yeah yeah yeah the yoga thing and
the chef thing right and then
so like you've you've asked them each a
few questions
you've cracked a few jokes
they're all laughing at your jokes i
know that's important to you
i've instructed them i don't want to i
don't want to be put on the well i don't
even know you don't know that i've
instructed him to do that but they're
really into your jokes i don't like man
once you once you once you've
interviewed all six and like you're
still kind of torn because these are all
like top-notch chefs
uh are they telling me like what the op
menu options are uh yeah they're telling
you whatever you wanna know we'll have a
southwest to make your decision or
whatever
at that point they all rush towards the
wall and they kick it down and they say
you don't have to choose we're each
gonna vie for your approval and then the
first one brings out a little morsel and
and it describes it so it's a chef's
competition show and i'm the judge yes
and you're eating it and you're like
cracking a few jokes
and then what does that go from the next
chef comes out
and is like topping that and like
they're really competitive
is this being filmed no this isn't a
pilot no
okay hey i don't want it to be i don't
feel like pressure this is your day okay
nobody's watching
are you there
yeah
where are you getting a massage oh so
it's just literally happening in the
same building yeah
and then
i mean they're like being they're
they're like aggressively competitive
with each other like they are starting
to hate each other and they're like you
think they're gonna fight and the things
they're saying to each other are just
horrible but the things they're saying
to you are amazing
and then
it's like you're watching a reality show
where they're like are they gonna pull
each other's hair out you know it's like
uh it doesn't have to get violent
well it gets a little trashy so this is
where the reality show part of it comes
in they start making out with each other
in a hot tub okay it's like there's like
you know all the things in the on those
shows that you watch is one of them like
a mail-order bride yeah mail-order chef
okay so we got like 90-day fiance
i like this right they're like all these
chefs are just like
they're either fighting or they're like
making out but they're all making great
food and they're all making great the
best food you've ever had
i think you may have inadvertently like
created
an experience that i want to actually
create for people
when you go to a restaurant and the
people make the food for you and they're
all fighting and making out and stuff
yeah you like the idea see this is a
great is it no hold on isn't this this
is like just going to that beverly hills
restaurant that what's her name
owns
the the woman from the show oh good well
i'll just take you there
uh what's the show vander vanderpump
yeah vanderpump this is like just going
to at least at vanderpumps restaurant
which i've never can you believe i've
never been there
man well we're going there for dinner
but i'm gonna be the only one there
right
shut it down where's my wife
because i would want my wife to be there
for that for sure
okay
fine she's there poof all of a sudden
she's there you press a button you press
the wife button she comes up out of the
floor oh there's a wife there's a wife
button yeah
yeah and she does it and she comes up
and presses again she goes down
yeah
yeah she's
i wouldn't call it a cage
hey but hey she can't get out i should
listen no
no what i'm just saying you're digging
holes for me that i'm not i don't want
you asked for a cage you want this to be
in a cage well is it like a stripper
cage
i don't know what those are
if it's like a if it's like a sexy
stripper cage she can get out she knows
it and of course it's not locked from
the outside or anything
it's all yeah
yeah so that's there
um okay
my wife is my wife is hanging from a
sexy
cage it doesn't hang it comes out of the
floor
well i think once it comes out of the
floor then it attaches to something and
then it hangs she says
that's sexier yeah yeah
and she can get and she does whatever
she wants she wants to stay up there and
dance or she wants to open the cage and
come sit next to me
either thing because that's her day you
know she's this isn't her perfect it's
definitely not her perfect day no but
i'm saying her as she relates to me and
my brother she would enjoy watching this
she still
maintains all her own will
okay uh and then we gotta get back to
you so it's a culinary orgy
like ifc not ifc ufc so they're having
sex the chefs are having sex i don't
know what they do on these trashy shows
you watch well there's nobody filming
this they could do lots of things
hey it's your day i don't know about
that though i don't think they should
have sex i think they just make out
i mean
it's up to you
and to them
okay like consent is is always a part of
this
of course i know this is all
hypothetical yeah yeah right but it is
going to happen uh okay so yeah you know
what you just you you just caught up
with my perfect day i maybe surpassed it
yeah so now i got to get back to you
um
now
i'm trying to think of
because i want
what i'm gonna what i'm sort of
requesting for my day which i'm now go
in in terms of a categories i feel like
there's another there's an afternoon
activity and so i'm trying to think what
is the afternoon activity
you know first of all we haven't even
thought about food yet for you
so or you just want another smoothie
you just want to be filled up with
another smoothie like a second smoothie
um i mean i could probably go for a
cheeseburger at this point okay so you
want a cheeseburger
yeah a really good one where from um
like a you know like a shake shake
on a shake shack burger
for lunch yeah
okay that could probably be arranged all
right great it's a little easier than
sick chefs they're going to screw each
other when they make food
i said they were going to fight okay
you're right okay i'm sorry they were
so
what are we going to do in the end what
are you going to do in the afternoon now
you're a big mountain biker guy
yeah i wouldn't say i'm the best at it
but i do really enjoy it okay i can do
this that's it's very strenuous though
i got it for you
i'm getting a chopper
uh there's a helipad on top of the
cottage
we can get a helipad we can get one of
those malibu places that's got a helipad
this is just one night we can do that
and if also if you're gonna i've got the
whole six chef's thing happening so it's
a helicopter there's a big it's a
helicopter with like a mountain bike
attached to it
your mountain bike the pilot shows up
he's like
you point at a mountain
i will take you there you roll down it
and then i pick you up and you point at
another mountain oh wow that's what your
afternoon is that's pretty cool man
that's pretty cool do you want a friend
do you want your friend your buddy nick
to come along
because because he like feels like he
might keep you safe
um
sure yeah now that you've i mean i can't
say no at this point he's listening
uh okay so that's your afternoon you can
just literally never have to pedal
it's just all downhill mountain
biking but not not too aggressive what
you point at the mountain okay yeah yeah
yeah
and then you tell the chopper you're
like anytime i get uncomfortable
i'm gonna shoot a flare you're given a
flare
and he just comes well you can't shoot a
flare in the middle i could be connected
by a tether to the copter and he could
be so that way if i fall off the bike
it's taut enough that i don't injure
myself
that'd be cool
you want a tether i want a tether
i don't know if i can work that on a cop
a chopper you want a chopper tether that
sounds like
very dangerous
i don't think i should have do do the
tether i'm just saying because i think
this is funny that's good because like
you can go to ski resorts in the summer
and you can take the lift up but that
takes time yeah and then you're in your
mountain biking back down so what are
you going to do next
what is it you want to do
oh yeah i mean you've just eaten you
probably want to go somewhere and eat
again no not yet okay i could give you
some hints um
i think maybe you want us maybe you want
to i think you want to go to a place
that that no one has access yes it's
exactly how you know me so well i was
going to say i want to go to a place
that no one has access to really yeah
exactly that i love that kind of thing
uh so but i mean we're talking la
there's like parts of there's got to be
parts of la that that nobody
is is off limits
like if you
you have to go through this culvert
definitely underground coming from like
the la river and then you're going to go
underneath
dodger stadium where like uh you know
mickey rooney had like a lounge
sure nooks and crannies
i love nooks and crannies yeah and i and
i don't like some
tour guide
and then like a family from ohio so
you're giving a headlamp and you're with
me what a head lamp and a map
no no i need it i want to i no i i do
want a guy
i want a guide i just don't want a tour
guide yeah i don't this is not a
sanctioned tour
this is like an expert like i read about
those french catacombs under paris or as
we say paris
and uh there's an la version of that
there's got to be something in la i want
to know that i want to know about this
stuff man i want to be down there i also
like visiting
um
places like nice places that you like
i've always wanted to go to the biltmore
estate with nobody else there you know
okay
so you come out of the other end of the
tunnel system
you may have to take a shower we'll have
a portable shower for you
and there will be snacks like little
smokies
like ever so often the the um appetizers
the the uh that your guide your sherpa
uh he's gonna give you little smokies
what about those little meatballs that
your mom makes in the jelly yeah my mom
will make you her meatballs
she will not be there
okay cheeseboard she's gonna have to
ship them when you come out at the other
end of the tunnel
it's that um
in beverly hills there's that there's
that castle there
there's that really nice mansion
that you can go in i can't remember what
it's called um
it's like there's an estate
in beverly hills you're gonna pop out
there and that's been shut down and used
for me you can go around there and you
can you're gonna find which room
you're gonna have your conjugal visit in
oh okay so i hit the wall again hit the
button
and she's going to come out she's going
to come up in the
okay this is good because i was about i
was thinking it's about time for that
yeah yeah right
so you come out of the yeah i mean the
traversing in the tunnel is taking a
while you're you're in the you're in the
like it's like the
the west coast biltmore it's it's in the
beverly hills how come i don't know
about this look that up i don't know
what it is it's like
some sort of estate mansion beverly
hills
um this sounds cool man yeah and then
it's like you can any any bed you want
any any any hard surface
multiple surfaces we can
make love in multiple rooms yeah yep
okay
you and your wife just clarify
i will not be there my wife and i will
make love in multiple rooms right it's
like you never know what they can do
with the edit of this thing they edit
this stuff down
they put it on they put it on tick tock
the tumbler folks will have a ball with
that one put it on tick tock they put it
on twitter
um
are you finding it
greystone
graystone
graystone mansion
mansion mansion
you'll love it
okay the gardens are even amazing i was
gonna say i love gardens well you know
you could have a little i'm a sucker for
gardens man huntington gardens have a
little smoke break in the gardens i
spend all day there but it's the part i
don't like is the other people no other
people are there i love this get lost in
the hedges
yes
and then um
can the six chefs come back no mansion
no that's over
that's over it's never going to be as
good as it was the first time okay well
what's the new food well you know what
hold on so yeah okay we're not to that
yeah because because i've got you in
mountain biking you've had a tough day
honey i really need
yeah i'm gonna need to get cleaned up
well after you've
what's the coolest way to get cleaned up
you know
like what's the most enjoyable way to
get cleaned up
uh
sponge bath hot tub hot tub okay
so okay not in a conversation home
that's simple
you come back
you come back you're gonna go to a new
place do you want to go to a new place
because i can rent two places yeah i
don't want to go back to that place yeah
that place is old they kicked the wall
down
that place is a piece of crap now
yeah i want to go back to it so we're
going to a new place
you know
i kind of feel like you might be ready
for like
a little bit of a little bit of a crowd
you know like you may want to go
you may want to go to a
uh a party
of your
that peop hand-picked friends and i
think it's too early for that that it's
still daylight
oh i was thinking this is like five or
six o'clock
i'm trying to create a dinner situation
for you
yeah i got to eat something dinner and
evening situation i mean i did give you
a hint
in your thing i kind of i kind of i kind
of need my version
of oh you have to hit the like button
too
yeah and uh okay well um that's easy um
afternoon delight they call it i think
at one of the tops of the mountains
because you like to have sex outdoors
your wife is there on one of those
blankets that y'all like
okay
uh i mean maybe there's a and because
christie is a jerk and because christy
is scared just logistics i hate to go
off on logistics because christy is
scared of flying
she's been sedated like b.a barakas oh
god
and she's blowing she's tethered down
from the copter
well
she's just floppy i'm just saying she
didn't know like she knew she was going
to be at the top of the mountain and
she's not there and she's awake when you
show up but i'm just saying that groggy
man no no well i'm just saying she's
totally at ease
because she was she was sedated
you're doing it again this is such a
such a you there's no need to go down
this path
for a conjugal visit it's unnecessary
and you're using the terms you're using
are all wrong
i'm saying that the writing's on the
wall man okay better idea you roll down
oh this is good you pick there's one i
don't think i'm going to take
the bike down the last time
no no but you know i am going to come
down but i'm going to come down on
something else
a horse yeah oh really that's a good
idea what were you thinking a horse
okay i'm a gallop down the mountain on a
horse you come down the mountain on a
horse that has been sedated and put at
the top i mean
somebody's got to get sedated here just
logistically
okay
and then you come down someone else
could have written it up right but
here's this is where this is where the
beverly hills aspect comes in for you so
have you noticed that like when you're
hiking up in like runyon canyon and
that's that part of town
there's these super rich people who have
these giant estates and they've got like
trails that come off of the main trail
and you can yeah so you you horse it
down one of these trails and you go into
like the nicest backyard that i can get
somebody to agree to let me in
and
we have created a scene
where it looks like
you are riding your horse into the
garden of eden
okay oh
sorry i'm naked you're well you you have
a choice to do what you want but your
wife
is only wearing
fig leaves
and she is there she's surrounded by
fruit do fig leaves get sticky or just
the figs
she's surrounded by figs and she's
wearing fig leaves oh great leaves she's
like eve
right yeah and we've got the garden of
eden theme in the back and there's and
we've got trained animals
in pairs okay so a little noah's ark too
i'm just throwing a lot of biblical
references okay yeah because you're
going to get to know her in the biblical
sense in the back of this
backyard okay
so
you you come down and there you're
washed in a very
uh
you know i get off the horse and i'm
like i'm being like
hosed down there's a there's a there's a
group of people who
drop you into a bat to it like a a a
like a claw foot tub with heated water
like it's kind of a it's a little bit of
a hot tub situation okay yeah uh getting
you ready you know like getting this is
like getting the king ready
to go into the room milk bath
any kind of liquid you want that i can
get hold of
yeah yeah except mercury
and then
you have an outdoor visit with your wife
the horse turns turns around turns away
okay
the horse doesn't watch
um
nothing makes me horny like looking at
the ass end of a horse
and then
i don't care if the horse watches okay
and then from there is where we start
moving into the evening activities yeah
yeah okay
well
you're skipping a step here oh i got to
clean up
no
i mean
uh
the perfect day for me has to include a
nap
okay well you make love and you fall
asleep in your wife's arms
yeah outside we got we've got like
mosquito candles so you're not gonna get
bitten by anything no no no
you're gonna sleep outside it's a breeze
is this exactly the breeze that you want
okay you take a nap
like a 90 minute nap as long as you want
yeah i mean i'm willing to give up 90
minutes of my perfect day to just be in
slumberland
uh okay back to me
what are you doing for me where where do
we leave you off
uh you're in the i'm in the graystone
mansion by myself lost
link where are you it's taking a 90
minutes so you got to wait for 90
minutes no no i need to wait because i'm
i'm with my wife we've made love in
every room
if i if i can do that
well you'll be allowed to
we may not be we've
okay
uh it's the thought that counts you know
um i have a very specific idea of what i
want to happen now i mean just so you
know you're gonna get into an outfit
like i think the outfit matters to you
the outfit matters to me i'm not the one
wearing the matching suits in the doing
the dj's hey i'm just i'm playing
i'm in an outfit yeah you're in your
outfit it's uh
it's
uh it's got a big collar um
okay
what what well there's something there's
something there's a place i'm trying to
lead you
what about what have i been talking
about lately is what i want to do as i
get older and also what i want to start
doing like on a semi-regular basis here
in la with
pedicures
[Music]
your toes need work man no socially
oh
okay so you want you want to uh have
afternoon coffee
with an author
no no no no
i told you about my idea for these
engine me engineering these
social
oh yeah soirees
like a conversational soiree
where oh where and i gave you the
example of the one that i heard about my
wife shared with me on twitter because
she knows i'm into this idea and i'm
trying to begin
curating these experiences i'm really
into this idea well
was i inebriated when you told me this
no hold on i'll remember it i've talked
about it multiple times yeah this is a
this is a themed party with an
assignment
and oh
you want me to you want me to take your
idea as if it's mine and then give it
back to you well because i remember it
well my idea don't i can't say it's not
i'm planning your perfect it's not my
idea
the example idea was somebody on twitter
who already did it rhett is going to
show up at
an amazing event space and let you know
what we've been you you're in the hills
i i'm trying to figure out where where
the locale is
i think i think you're on a
i think you're on a a rooftop
event space
as the sun sets
where
the most interesting people that
fascinate you
show up from all walks of life
and they've each
prepared their assignment which is a
powerpoint presentation okay
i think you have to can i just give the
context because i think you it's an it's
i want to get the context
plan your day man no no i want you to
come up with what the theme is because
go ahead okay so
i told my wife i've been talking about
this
that as i get older one of the things
i'm interested in doing is curating
social
settings for people to do weird things
in that are just funny and interesting
now this is why we have game night in
our house which we haven't had since the
pandemic but like the reason we have it
is i love like getting people together
eating something interesting or fun and
then doing something fun together and i
just kind of i love being partaking but
i also just kind of love curating it and
watching it happen right
yeah and
my wife sent me this twitter post where
a woman was like
i just went to something called parm and
powerpoint
where right the theme of the party was
you show up and everyone eats chicken
parm
and then everyone has prepared a short
powerpoint presentation in a niche area
of their knowledge and when you get
there they mix them all up and you have
to
you have to do the powerpoint
presentation from somebody else
for the whole isn't that brilliant and i
think that's so fun i love this kind of
i've come up with one that i'm calling
milk shakespeare
that's my first idea where we all have
uh
alcoholic milkshakes and then we all are
given assignments and you divide up into
small groups and you you do uh
shakespeare themed
uh plays
of with a theme and like a like a rule
like a stipulation like you draw a theme
and a stipulation then you go with your
little group and you write it and then
you come and i'll perform it inebriated
with each other on these drunk
milkshakes
i'm going to do that for our game by the
way do you feel like you can't just do
the powerpoint thing because i no that's
also a good idea to come up with a new
one because you're planning my day i
don't i can't do parm in powerpoint
because that's already been done every
time i do it it's going to be different
and i've got this vision
when i'm old i just want to have a place
where
again it makes me sound like a pimp i
don't i'm not trying to sound like a
pimper like hugh hefner or something but
i just want to be an old guy who curates
experiences you want to be a king and
then i sit up in the corner smoking a
pipe and i'm like
this is a great powerpoint you know i
just want to i just love the idea of
people doing the shakespeare resonates
with a different type of person than the
powerpoint that's the that's the beauty
of it and so then over time i just don't
think i think i think the powerpoint
should still be on the table that's my
humble request is that you you you say
hey start with powerpoint that's a good
one too man it is it's better than shake
the milkshakes better than shakespeare
but that's just my personal preference
like jenna likes to shakespeare she
likes milk shakespeare but like getting
together and doing drama stuff is is
it's a it's an acquired taste for some
people but and but so is giving a
powerpoint but i love watching people
come out of their shell and do things
like unless they don't but when you have
a powerpoint like you have some
structure and then if you're struggling
through it it's still there you have a
backbone it's like yeah yeah or we just
come up with a whole new one
yeah like um
like
sausage and sachet yeah whatever that is
it's when you eat sausages and then you
have to uh do a little sachet you have
to do a little you have to you have to
invent a dance event
but the brilliance is that you've
prepared something that then somebody
else gets
like that that's what really puts the
parm and powerpoint over the top the
moment that you told me that they switch
them up it became a brilliant idea
because yeah that's what makes
everything everybody is out of their
comfort zone equally what i'm telling
you is that that is an idea and there
are an unlimited infinite number of
great ideas you actually thought about
it and only came up with shakes and
shakespeare
shakes milk shakespeare
and and that's i mean now just i farted
that idea i'm just saying i like do you
know that movie about something else you
could prepare what's the name what's the
name of that movie where the woman
marries into the family and they have
her over at the house and they then they
try to kill her
it's a horror movie that's kind of funny
but like that family has this crazy
thing that they do i don't want to do
that because i don't want anybody to die
but like i've always loved the idea of
like these
even if it's like a murder mystery kind
of thing but yeah but i did and i've
never been been to one and i've never
been a part of one so i want to go to
like the most awesome version of that
that's how i want to end my day with the
people that i love i love that and then
also some just interesting people who
you might be able to get to show up
yeah i might have to pay them i
definitely like uh
like i like dinner with um some close
friends we're now planning our own days
but then moving to something that's more
of an event well do you want to just
maybe our days end at this event
together yeah i like that oh that's harm
and powerpoint
or something better that we haven't
thought of yet
switching it up is what's so brilliant
yeah but i'm just saying that was a
great idea but we can have a better you
want to take credit for the idea no i'm
just saying i i like the idea of every
time people show up it's different it's
different i i get that um okay so
you've recovered from making love with
your wife in the garden
i've recovered from making love with my
wife in multiple rooms in a mansion
we are taken to with our wives to this
incredible event space where we meet the
friends that we love
uh and then some like other interesting
people that have been paid off to be
there yeah like an author yeah a
scientist somebody who studies something
really interesting a yeah like
a like a highly rated plumber yeah no
influencers
no influence yes yeah stay away from
them um
yeah
and you know what everybody all the
chefs can show up the chefs come like
the the masseuses and yoga people
they're all there like the guy everybody
everybody's it's like the end of a movie
yeah yeah the helicopter pilot comes in
yeah
yes the horse is there the horse is
inside people are like such a big house
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is great
the horse is there i love it yeah yeah
yeah and we and it this goes until like
this goes until we pass like three in
the morning yeah i'm not big into
passing out
i don't ever get so drunk that i pass
out in fact this never happened but i
think yeah i'm not i've never done it
either and i don't i don't want to i
think i might do it tonight i don't want
i don't
i mean not tonight
on this night i might get so drunk
the day
my perfect day to be the worst day well
one of those masseuses comes up and like
hooks you up to like an iv and gives you
a vitamin b shot in your ass and stuff
as you go to sleep you'll be fine
okay all right
hey that's it we we ended it that was
fun man i mean
part of it there's a therapy to this
like we got to do this part of it made
me feel like
i experienced it yeah like i actually
feel some endorphins
i feel i feel some uh
some psychosomatic positivity
this has been good yeah man don't blow
it with your wreck and i feel like
we could engineer at least a portion of
that
you know
yeah i think we could like why not make
that happen why not make that a reality
yeah
okay one eight eight eight earpod one
um call in and let us know what you
think about that
i have a wreck that is a little unusual
and my wreck
ironically is that i think
uh if you have something that's hurting
on you you should go to the doctor
this is why i'm gonna this is why i'm
telling you this
so i think i've
i've disclosed that my
right shoulder has been bothering me
and in in it's been bothering me for
like
15 years like i haven't been able to
really throw a baseball in the same way
you can see that in the evidence of when
we threw the
the pitches out at the dodgers stadium
and mine bounced before it got to the
plate
because i was
i can't i can't get my arm back anymore
and i know but i'm not i don't need to
throw things very often right and so
it's just kind of like ah this is just
something i'll deal with i don't want to
go to the doctor because i don't want
them to tell me that i need surgery
because i'm not going to get surgery and
what else am i going to do
so i went to an orthopedist
who was like you know
i think you should just we should just
do a few weeks of physical you know like
six weeks of physical therapy yeah to
see if that starts fixing things and i
went to a physical therapist who really
got committed to trying to figure out
what was wrong
very much like i you probably had a tear
at some point and it's kind of stiffened
up here in the back and you've got some
impingement whatever
long story short is that i just been
doing these exercises and like with
every day that passes the mobility comes
back right it's that simple i
i talked about going to the physical
therapist and fixing my shoulder i've
talked about going to physical
therapists all the time on this show i
well i understand that but for some
reason i was recommending it constantly
by implying it but for some reason i
well first of all
i've always known that i should be doing
this yeah and the reason i'm making it a
wreck is because somebody out there this
is like one of those preachers somebody
out there right now you hear you hear me
for you you need to come up front and
give your life to jesus
give your life to the physical therapist
what you need to do actually uh
is you need to go to the doctor
if you've got something that's like ah
that's kind of bothering me a little bit
it's funny just go go to the doctor you
know
go to the doctor
get it checked out
because sometimes it's as simple as
here's a list of exercises that you can
do
that are going to improve your life and
maybe you i might even be throwing a
baseball in a few weeks hey who knows
man what a great day
i just had a great day hashtag your
biscuits one eight eight eight earpod
one
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]